foreign
[Music]
I am told we are now live on the
internet I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report we've got another Friday
Round Table Extravaganza for you and
this is a Reuben report first because
joining me today is host of the Andrew
klavan show and author of a strange
habit of Mind Andrew Clavin and host of
The Young Heretics show and author of
how to save the West Spencer Clavin and
yes you may have noticed they both have
the same name because they are a
father-son Duo it is the Clavin clan on
the Reuben report welcome guys it's
great we have to stop meeting like this
Dad
I barely see you except you should find
a more classy place to get together
right now absolutely well you really
should I just had a feeling maybe you
guys you're very busy successful careers
maybe you just hadn't connected in a
while and I wanted to bring you together
here on the Reuben report mostly to talk
about trans issues and other crazy
things happening in the world
but before we do anything because you
are a father-son Duo Andrew you have
written what like 87 books and Spencer
you've only written one that must be
tough as a father two son two I have two
books two sorry two two I do I do know
that you have written two yeah yeah yeah
no but it's it's very disappointing I
resisted being a writer for the longest
time because it's sort of like if you're
Stephen King's son you probably
shouldn't go into mystery writing but uh
eventually there was just like nothing I
could do so now dad gets to say that he
always has one up on me which is
probably Andrew how many how many at
this point it's it's over 30 I believe
it's something like 33 but you'll you
may notice a slight difference between
the two of us uh I will do this show and
then probably pass away whereas many
years
to catch up with my number so I think
he's doing all right yeah I do have a
head start relative to time I guess
exactly the hair exactly fair enough yes
you're not taking in those rays you know
the thoughts come right into my head
without the interruption speaking of
those rays real quick before we get into
the meat of the show and we're going to
recap all the kind of craziness of the
week from the woke stuff to Ukraine and
some Trump to Santa stuff and a bunch
more uh Andrew you mentioned that you're
actually on vacation in California right
now which sounds completely psychotic
you live in Virginia
um Spencer you're obviously uh in
Nashville with the daily wire guys but
Andrew real quick uh because you've been
in the biz for a long time we mentioned
right before we started that there's
this writer strike right now which now
the actors are getting in on I thought
maybe you could just give us a little
like minute synopsis on what you think's
going on there and then we'll jump into
everything else well the actors joining
the writers is a big deal because it
will shut down production it'll even
shut down promotion of big movies coming
out the issues are really not that
complicated the streaming revolution has
changed the business and everybody you
know some people want the business to go
back the way it was but there are some
serious issues like residuals who used
to be on TV if you had a hit show you
collected money every time the show was
played now with streaming they just put
it up there and you get the money up
front but you never get any of the
success money you don't succeed when the
show succeeds so there and AI is the
other thing because so many TV shows are
so by road that AI could write them
easily the thing is we're not going back
to the past I mean AI is here it's going
to do what it does actors should have a
right to their images you shouldn't be
able to use their images without
permission uh and streaming is here to
stay and you've just got to figure out a
way to get paid but what's not coming
back is the day of the you know 20
writer writer rooms uh that lasted for
26 weeks those shows are just gone and
you can't bring them back and as that
you know and the people that they're
fighting against the people these unions
can be a little too Lefty a little bit
too uh happy to take to the streets on
the one hand but the people that they're
up against are people who would
literally rip the back of your spine out
for a nickel and so and so it is going
to be an interesting uh interesting
thing to see who caves in in first
because eventually they'll want to bring
the business back online Spencer I'll
give you I'll give you one swing on that
do you think as the youngest of the
panel here I'm kind of right in between
you guys uh do you think like the
average younger person even cares if
Hollywood collapsed because they're
getting their entertainment in a million
other places at this point I'm not even
sure if the studios care that the
writers are are on strike they have to
you know find out through Twitter but no
I mean I
um I I wonder about this my general AI
take in terms of writing is that because
what these machines do is they churn up
all the text on the internet and they
basically spit out an approximation of
the average of it
um they're going to replace the the mids
they're going to replace the mid-level
writers who as Dad said are already
churning stuff out that could have been
written by a machine and now it will be
and so there's some degree of Hope for
me in this and you know God forbid that
a Hollywood writer might actually have
to come up with an original idea
something it's not just like you know a
Hollywood uh X-Men 5 the awokening or or
whatever
um but I yeah it's also possible that
I'm already kind of out of date in that
I watch movies at all that I still go to
the theater I actually saw Indiana Jones
12 for my sounds and I know I know um
and definitely you know that's a great
example of something that you could
probably catch at GPT to turn out in
about five minutes a lot of the New
Media is obviously much more exciting
stuff that people are doing on rumble on
tick tock on locals whatever
um so it's it's possible that the age of
Cinema is just kind of passing away to
begin for the record it's worth noticing
you should actually just notice this
this thing that just happened with sound
of freedom because conservatives tend to
be very stupid about culture they don't
realize what a huge deal this is this is
a non-hollywood distributed distribution
is the hardest thing that's where the
that's where the big guys take over and
they didn't distribute it through
Hollywood they distributed through Angel
Studios which does the chosen they
humiliated Indiana Jones by having two
thousand fewer
um theaters and yet doing better
business for a day and Better Business
theater by theater all together this is
a Christian picture the left hates it
it's against child molesting so the left
doesn't understand it what you know
what's wrong with child molesting they
think and yet it was a huge success uh
completely independently done
this is a this is a big threat to the
business coming down the pike and it's
all to the good for those of us on the
right yeah you know there's so much
Prestige lag that as conservatives we
sit here and we shake our fists and we
say oh the uh you know the Ivy Leagues
and the Hollywood institutions and all
the major culture centers they've been
totally captured they just produce
garbage and it's politically motivated
and we still extend our kids to Ivy
League schools because we want the fancy
credential we want the you know the the
note on the degree that's going to make
us look special in the eyes of the
people that hate us and gradually with
movies like this that you're talking
about that I think we start to catch up
slowly realize that you can actually
make stuff now in these totally new ways
it's kind of renegade ways and that will
replace some of those old supposedly
prestigious institutions by the way I
should mention uh Spencer you said X-Men
five I actually am working on a reboot
of the X-Men but it's ex Dash men X-Men
trans Dylan Mulvaney
as Professor X
etc
etc but speaking of Hollywood
speaking of Hollywood let's get to the
first segment uh actor Brian Cox did you
guys watch the session by any chance
uh-huh okay I'm actually like wait don't
don't say the ending because I am in
episode I am in season four episode
seven I watched it last night I Don't
Know How It Ends don't say anything
about that okay
actor Brian Cox who of course plays
Logan Roy in the show he was on with
Piers Morgan a couple days ago talking
about social media and wokeness and his
overall effect on society take a look
are things worse now or is our
perception of Life worse because of
things like social media inflaming
everything well I think I don't think
social media helps
it hinders rather than helps and I think
it points up
too readily inadequacies that we can
actually and the whole woke well we've
talked about this before the whole work
culture I think is truly awful and the
shaming culture and the shaming culture
which I really feel quite strong this
incessant need to shame yeah and bury
people like I don't know where it comes
from I don't know who's who are the
Arbiters of these this shaming right and
it's very hard to pin them down and it
turns out it's usually a bunch of
Millennials right and who and who gave
them the Halos I don't know I mean they
think it's children well I mean I
suppose in a way they're probably saying
well you've all screwed it up so we may
as well do something about it but it's
it's from the wrong principle it's the
wrong it comes from their own place
in my audience knows I'm not a fan of
just randomly throwing to actors to get
their opinions on things because usually
their opinions are wrong but what I
thought was interesting about this is
he's he's old school in a certain sense
but he's a liberal he is a Hollywood
liberal by his own estimation uh but
Andrew hearing some people in Hollywood
finally coming around on this thing
maybe means that the worm is turning
right oh yeah it's been devastating I
mean I'm out here now I'm talking to
friends who are in the business and it's
just been devastating to the
collegiality of the business of the
sense of fun that the business requires
it's it is a fun business as you're out
here telling stories uh making stuff up
and having you know people jump off
cliffs and all that stuff and if you're
not having a good time the audience is
not going to have a good time and if you
notice a really good way to notice
what's happening is watching what is
highlighted on Netflix for several
months after the George Floyd riots and
the following racial Panic that struck
it seems like the entire West you would
see like this black lives matter
collection on Netflix and I would think
like black lives matter is a maoist con
group of con men I'm not watching the
black lives matter collection and then I
would notice that some of my favorite
actors were in this stuff it was you
know Denzel Washington was there one of
my favorites and I thought I'm not going
to press on that button I'm not going to
bring up a Denzel Washington film much
as I love him if it's under a black
lives matter rubric because I want to
send a message to Netflix
slowly that stuff has disappeared slowly
kind of mainstream non-niche material
like extraction you know Heroes going
out and saving the day is coming back it
doesn't work it has destroyed I mean so
much of what's happening in the industry
is brought on by technology but so much
is also brought on by this stupid woke
philosophy this idea that everything is
wrong about the West which is really
let's face it the engine has been the
engine of freedom for thousands of years
the most creative the most artistic the
deepest culture that the world has ever
seen and you know are we flawed ha you
know we're filled with people of course
we're flawed but the idea that we
shouldn't be celebrating who we are what
we do the idea that we should constantly
be slapping ourselves in the head for
things that happen hundreds of years ago
it's just absurd and it's ugly and it's
pessimistic and it's dark and people
don't want to go to the theater and see
it so so they can watch more
entertaining things on Tick Tock and by
the way it's not that it's just
destroying the creative part of
Hollywood which is very obvious look
what it's done to everything Star Wars
for example would be a good one who Bob
Iger basically put out a video yesterday
in an interview saying oh like we're
kind of scaling back on it like he's
admitting they destroyed it now but you
guys will find this interesting the guy
the the lighting guy who did two of my
Studios when I lived in Los Angeles was
a multiple time Emmy award-winning
lighting guy throughout the the business
he had been in the business for about 40
years about 65 years old uh he was a
liberal his entire life and and we would
talk about politics sometimes and he'd
be like Dave you're kind of crazy and
then during kovid he was basically told
he is a white guy of a certain age and
he should retire that's what the studio
told him and then I handed him my book
my first book and he read it and he said
Dave now I get it and he's basically
hanging on to a career that that almost
doesn't exist anymore not having
anything to do with his skills because
those are pretty awesome but having
everything to do with his skin color uh
Spencer Hollywood crumbling you're in
Nashville you guys are building a lot of
things over there pretty good right well
you know you walk into the daily wire
offices and every third person that you
meet is a refugee from ESPN Disney I
mean ABC these these enormous media
corporations that are bleeding top
talent because of this idiot philosophy
that white people don't get to speak or
eat anymore essentially you know it's a
genuine self-own that the universities
have done as to themselves as well
Harvard Yale Princeton are now
effectually effectively credentializing
institutions for woke theology they
don't offer you an education they offer
you the impromat or of a really sick
philosophy and that's kind of what
Hollywood's doing to itself as well I
love watching Brian Cox play the real
life Logan Roy in that interview I mean
this is one of a number of guys uh Logan
Roy is one of them but the guy from
Parks and Recreation the Nick Offerman
in character the Alec Baldwin character
in 30 Rock the left thinks these people
are the bad guys and they present them
as these sort of mean nasty antagonist
men that say nasty things but they don't
understand that the reason audiences
love that shows is because of those guys
who say these uncomfortable things that
are now forbidden by this weird speech
Cove that they've all imposed upon
themselves and as dad is saying you know
you watch the way that this has just
strangled people in the business by the
way not just white people I can't
imagine it's all that much fun to be
Denzel Washington you know and and one
of the great actors of your generation
and to have your whole Opus your whole
life's work reduced to this kind of
tokenism black lives matter great that's
what we're going to say about the man
who just delivered one of the best
performances of Macbeth in living memory
it's it's appalling and I'm I imagine
that nobody likes it so I love you know
that that Brian Cox is saying it I I
hope that you know it keeps uh I hope it
keeps going but sort of selfishly I kind
of want all of these people you know
keep doing it keep alienating all these
great people like come bring them over
really wire why not fear not they are
not going to stop because some images
leaked this morning I I honestly thought
this was made up it's so insane I really
thought it was made up but uh truth is
far Stranger Than Fiction these days uh
this is from the end wokeness Twitter
account uh that what you are seeing
right there so of course the original
Seven Dwarfs 1937 can we zoom in on the
original Seven Dwarfs okay so that's the
Seven Dwarfs that we all know and love
you got you're sleepy your doc you're
Dopey the rest of them the usual set of
characters they are now remaking this
into a live action movie and this is
real ladies and gentlemen look at this
these are the new Seven Dwarfs you may
know that there's only one dwarf there
that's one thing and then it's just a
diverse or whatever set of characters
and my favorite though is rapey look at
rapey over here look at that
that is definitely raping uh Andrew
Andrew again you've been in the business
your whole life they are wrecking
they're wrecking the dreams of the past
what we all know and love and then they
put this and it's like they're falling
on their sword Disney knows this is
going to be mocked it is going to lose
money but the activists at the company
simply don't care and Iger still I guess
despite being better than the previous
chapic he still is doing it Eiger made
an amazing statement yesterday where he
said that they're basically their TV and
streaming arms are not going to be core
to their company's profits yeah I
thought you guys yeah guess what well
also on that and then on the front page
of the Wall Street Journal uh last week
is a story saying that Disney parks are
emptying out and Iger is saying oh it's
absolutely absurd that we're trying to
sexualize our kid when Chris rupo has
released videotapes of their Skype
section assassins yeah Zoom sessions
where they're saying yeah we're going to
sexualize your kids uh yeah these guys
they do not know they're so surrounded
by people like themselves they do not
know we hate them and we do they do not
know that when we sit around and say you
know men can't become women you know you
listen live any way you please but men
can't become women they don't understand
that 99 of the country agrees with us
and the people who don't agree with us
are lying you know they agree with us
too and so they don't realize that until
I mean the big one is this Bud Light
thing with Dylan Mulvaney one can of
beer and they've fallen off the top the
number one beer in America has fallen
out of the top ten and is still losing
money just because people are offended
by being forced to lie by having the FBI
take their tweets off by being hounded
for speaking the simple truth that we
all know this is this is gutted the the
Hollywood industry and Spencer is
absolutely right you know you walk into
the daily wire and people are creating
things they're saying things they're
they're not afraid we're constantly
being taken off YouTube for speaking
simple truths I mean things that
everybody knows how long do they think
they can go so in this country this
diverse crazy free country how long do
they think they can go silencing the
truth before it just Rises up like a
gigantic dragon and bites them on the
ass and that is the moment that moment
is coming now I mean it's happening now
and only because conservatives don't
really understand the culture that well
Spencer I just had a great idea I don't
know if daily wire has the cash to get
the rights to Seven Dwarfs but I mean
Shapiro could easily play a dwarf come
on come on can they do what they did on
Lord of the Rings where they make us all
short because that would really that
would really rock you know here's the
really fascinating thing to me about
that either statement is you know he
tried to pass it off as oh we made too
much of this you know we put out too
many different spin-offs two flooded The
Zone with too much Star Wars content uh
let me tell you something I know Star
Wars fans I'm I'm married to one I'm
married to a Star Wars fanatic I
understand that fan base it is not
possible yes creating too much Star Wars
contradiction terms there's no such
thing if he thinks that what the problem
is is making too many Qui-Gon gin
spin-offs he's out of his mind and he
obviously knows it's not that he knows
that they put a gender studies professor
at the helm of a spaceship and said you
know fly it into the patriarchy which is
obviously an enormous catastrophe for
the people that watch those movies it is
such a self-owned because they have this
huge huge fanatical fan base built in
just this Bud Light has an obvious
Market everybody knows who buys that
beer and they cannot help themselves
from saying we hate you we hate you we
hate you and finally conservatives who
have absolutely no interest in
boycotting anything or doing anything
other than sort of sitting quietly at
home and raising their families have
realized that the only thing that's
going to make this stop is if you just
throw the beer into the Boston Harbor so
I think you know long may it last I you
know I tweeted it out this morning and
I'm not kidding what a beautiful ending
to the disastrous Star Wars Disney story
would be now that they've wrecked Star
Wars and they're also in the tank and
Iger admitted that the scientists beat
them like all of this stuff why doesn't
George Lucas come in I checked this
morning he's worth about 4.2 billion
dollars why doesn't he come in buy Star
Wars back on the cheap and then just fix
it and then I know he doesn't want
anything to do with it anymore because
the fans have all gone crazy but like
what a beautiful ending that would be
but let's let's shift to something else
uh also related somewhat to Hollywood
but I thought it had kind of bigger uh
cultural ramifications this Jonah Hill
story we covered this yesterday I'm just
going to read a bit from the daily wire
Jonah Hill's Surfer ex-girlfriend Sarah
Brady released a number of text messages
she said were attempts to control her
behavior Hill explained what he expected
of her with regard to the way she
presented herself if they were going to
be dating seriously one of the texts
read plain and simple if you need
surfing with men boundaryless
inappropriate relationships with men to
model to post pictures of yourself in a
bathing suit to post sexual pictures
friendships with women who are in
unstable places and from your wild
recent past Beyond getting a lunch or
coffee or something respectful I am not
the right partner for you if these
things bring you to a place of happiness
I support it and there will be no hard
feelings these are my boundaries for a
romantic partnership my boundaries which
with you they based on the way these
actions have hurt our trust Spencer let
me start with you on this one when I
read this yesterday I was like man not
only is everything he said there
completely within bounds even if someone
was arguing that to some degree okay he
doesn't want her to model maybe that's
like for somebody maybe that's a bit
much he was being clear and honest about
what he wants and it seems to me that
that is what young people need more than
anything these days no one is setting
boundaries no one's saying what they
want and understanding what they believe
to even say it in the first place I
thought it was beautiful and of course
the media is now calling him a
misogynist and the rest of it right I
mean this was a real mask off moment
because he's doing everything that men
are constantly being told to do he's
being forthright and clear about his
hopes for the relationship he's doing so
in a respectful way he's using language
pulled right out of a therapy session I
mean these are my boundaries he's
effectively attempting to just reach out
to this woman in and and say in the
plaintive storms possible I want a
committed relationship with you I don't
want to be competing between myself and
the internet essentially for your
affections for your love all of these
things I'm sure that that came along
with you know a corresponding commitment
on on his end and she spits this in his
face as like a form of abuse the metoo
movement has now cratered in on itself
from uh sort of understandable Creed
occur against rampant abuses in
Hollywood into like somebody said a man
sent me a text basically what all of
these complaints now amount to is
somebody hit on me and I wasn't into it
because the real secret behind all of
this is if you are if you have chemistry
with somebody and if you're flirting and
you're getting along and you're figuring
out a healthy way to build a
relationship together none of this stuff
is even remotely toxic who counts even
slightly as abuse the message that this
sends to me that this scent I think to a
lot of young men is there is nothing you
can do being a man is the crime and
therefore if you attempt anything at any
moment even if you don't say anything at
all if you just sit there ultimately you
are liable for some kind of exposure uh
for for shaming for for public abuse and
this is a completely untenable
unsustainable situation men and women of
Goodwill all know it the sexual ethic of
this neo-feminist movement is totally
played out totally could put something
better has to replace it and what's
interesting to me is that something
better quietly and secretly is replacing
it if you talk to young people
especially young women they know that
this stuff is junk it has destroyed
their lives it has set men and women
against each other when they should be a
delight unto one another and much like
the situation in Hollywood it simply
can't last reality is certain facts
about reality just come back around and
one of them is men and women aren't in a
war they're not fundamentally Dodgers to
another manhood is not a crime and I I
think the Jonah Hill thing was really
revealing to people not necessarily on
the right who just said look what does
this guy have to do he's doing
everything he's supposed to uh being
totally clear and forthright and he's
still getting burned for it something's
got to give Andrew as the Elder
Statesman of the group I'm going to go
old school reference on You All in the
Family late 70s early 80s or maybe it
was mid 70s to late 70s girls were girls
and men were men that's all he's saying
he's just saying I I'm telling you how I
feel you want to do this yes or no and
that's just too much for these people
absolutely there's just a big difference
between how the media is playing this
the kind of feminist media conglomerate
is playing the way actual people are
reacting to it there is right this
minute a a fascinating and I think
urgent movement rising up that is not
getting enough attention I'm covering it
on my show I don't see anybody else
covering it and that is a movement of
highly intelligent intellectual women
mostly toward the left who are suddenly
realizing this has not worked feminism
has not worked and birth control has not
worked birth control as one of these the
brightest of these women Mary
Harrington's points out is turned women
into sterile cyborgs who no longer have
any reason to refuse sex while at the
same time we are evolved to feel that
women's sexual apparatus which produces
human beings when you have sex with them
it should be protected and they should
be have the kind of uh virtue that it
takes to protect the ongoing Generations
all of that has prevailed them and has
put them in this position where they're
just being used you know there was a
hilarious absolutely hilarious
declaration that we should now refer to
the vagina as the bonus hole and I
thought well well which is which is the
bonus is the bonus that it feels good or
the bonus that it produces the baby
which which one comes first you know and
I think that they don't know they just
think that's what they think this is a
bonus hole the woman who won the
Pulitzer Prize for fiction uh I can't
even remember whether he or is a she or
one of the or both it's a guy a guy yeah
yeah and and said he he said something
like the you know the the is
like the universal vagina and I thought
well yeah I think so if women are now
sterile cyborgs that is true when you
dissociate yourself from the actual
human body you have dissociated yourself
from Humanity itself and this just
cannot stand it can't continue we
definitely got our attic context clip of
the day it's Andrew saying the
is the universal video Let's click that
and send that out to the internet
let's go over to Europe because
there was a big NATO Summit and uh
zielinski this guy from Ukraine he just
wants more cash and he wants in on NATO
so he can walk us to World War III
that's at least my humble opinion uh
here's a little clip of him telling us
what he wants because he just wants more
bear with us on the audio on this one we
have to bump it up so it's a little
crackly but you'll get it I think for
today three for your team questions the
first one is
weapon packages new weapon packages for
supporting our army on the battlefield
and that is one the second I think the
invitation to Nita and
um
we want to be
on the same page with everybody with all
the understanding and for today what we
what we what we hear and understand that
we'll have this invitation when security
measures
will allow
to be clear because it was a little
muddled he wants money he wants troops
he wants in on NATO Spencer
I'm a simple guy I don't really want him
to have any more of my money and I don't
really want to send our troops and I
also know that if he if Ukraine gets
into NATO literally it triggers World
War III within two seconds
you don't want that you don't want uh
nuclear Holocaust Dave when you're no
fun come on I'm living in Florida
everything's great at the moment it's
like not you know if I was still in Cali
maybe then right bring it on sweet
meteor of death no I mean look from the
beginning of this whole thing I have
said I don't blame zielinski for
shooting his shot I blame us for being
so feckless misdirected and weak that we
have no clue what to do except shovel
cash at this problem and virtue signal
about it the lack the total lack of
serious Statesman in Washington is what
this really reveals and look zielinski
is a an actual world leader in an actual
country having actual problems our
president and every Democrat surrounding
him and many indeed of our Republicans
as well are fantasy larpers living in
Bizarro come on who think that you can
just print paper money imagine dollars
into existence and that really nothing
ever happens because it's the end of
History so it's all just kind of a big
video game where we hang the Ukrainian
flag out our our window when I go to
visit my dad and mom in Alexandria there
are more Ukrainian flags hanging outside
the door than there are American flags
and they're often on top of the American
flag which I think is like a minor Act
of treason so
to me it's not that zielinski is some
kind of evil villainous scheming actor
it's that there is an enormous void of
seriousness Direction competency and
assertiveness at the heart of American
politics right now and zelenski is not
the only person who is going to step
into that void Xi Jinping wants to step
into that void Vladimir Putin wants to
step into that void the problem is us we
once we fix ourselves and get our house
in order a lot of this other stuff will
fall into place but we have serious work
to do before we get there Andrew Andrew
on the NATO side of this thing I mean
basically the deal with NATO is that if
a NATO member country is attacked that
NATO has to respond now that now in
essence we all know that really means
the United States has to respond it's
not like some random Nordic country is
going to attack Russia right so we know
it's on us but the fact that he's trying
to drive us there and actually I can't
believe I'm going to say this to slight
slight slight credit of the Biden
Administration we're not doing it yet
right NATO hasn't accepted them yet so
I'll I guess I'll give like the Tiny the
tiniest bit of credit there
um he wants to trigger world war three
it seems fairly obvious to me it's not
as if they get in and the next day
Russia is like okay we're done so he
knows what he's asking for
yeah I I don't think he won I think I
agree with Spencer on this I think he
wants to play his hand he wants to get
everything he can get and why shouldn't
he he represents Ukraine so he's
fighting through for Ukraine we
represent America so we're fighting for
I have no idea what you know you
actually don't know who we are right and
so what the one thing I will go on the
uh we'll go on the other direction here
is that I do believe that there is some
value in making Vladimir Putin look bad
the other day I heard Tucker Carlson
talking to Andrew Tate and they say
there are no good guys or bad guys in
war and that's only a half truth they're
not good guys anywhere but there are bad
guys in the war and Vlad Putin is a
genuine gangster you know scum and he is
making alliance with chi in China and to
make him humiliate him a little bit make
him you know put him on his back feet
what we don't have is we don't have a
plan uh you know somebody ought to you
know wake up Joe Biden and give him some
of the cocaine his son left behind just
Spruce them up for a minute and say
what's the plan Joe you know
I don't know yeah but I you know I think
we don't know what what we're fighting
for and I'm I'm not against giving Putin
problems if we don't have to send our
own people there and I'm I'm willing to
spend a little money on that I think
it's worthwhile he invaded another
country but I just don't know where
we're going with it I don't know where
where we can say we won and where we say
the war is over that you're right could
lead us to into World War II by the way
I'm glad you mentioned that Tucker Tate
interview because we played that clip
and I made basically the same comment
like it's not just as easy to say there
are no good guys and no bad guys if
someone's relentlessly attacking your
home and your family and you defend
yourself you actually are the good guy
in that case but let me just throw one
quick video on zelenski because guys
don't worry we're giving them an awful
lot but at least he's very thankful for
it and you gave us huge support I want
to thank to all Americans who understand
that it's more than 43 billions for
today it's big support and I understand
that it's all your money but but
you have to know that you spend this
money for for not not just fighting you
spend this money for our lives
and I think that we save
that the large for for Europe and for
for all the walls
Spencer bring us home quickly on this
one it's he thanks us it's all our money
and he's very thankful uh you're going
to be on this Earth past the time that
your dad and I are gone uh it's gonna be
extra your money by the way yeah
apparently I haven't prevented I think
once but both of you Shuffle off this
Mortal Coral is God will be about ready
to bring the curtain down so I don't
have to worry too much the whole thing
the Stars will fall in heaven I know
look the U.S is not a charitable trust I
will go that far in the direction of
real politique I think it's absolutely
true that unless you make moral
judgments about regimes and leaders you
can't think seriously about the whole
picture in war so as you guys were both
saying it's not it just it's so easy as
to say well you do what you have to do
and everything is relative to the
situation that you're in there are good
guys or at least there are less bad guys
uh when you're thinking about you know
who your allies are and what kinds of uh
civilizations you want to defend part of
our problem is that we have no idea what
our civilization is as dad was
indicating uh we basically our major
cultural export is like hormone blockers
for small children which is you know
extremely Bleak but accurate depending I
mean Al-Qaeda is painting over murals of
George Floyd in Afghanistan as we speak
you know now that we're now that we're
out but we don't exist it's like it's
very nice that zelenski is so so kind to
us to thank us for literally all of our
money
um but in reality in real world Politics
as we should be playing this the money
that we give to other countries is to
support our interests abroad and insofar
as supporting Ukraine does further those
interests I think there's a case to be
made that there's some money to be spent
there um but I'm actually not interested
in improving the quality of life of
other people simply for for the mere
sake of it there is something about this
discourse in America and overseas that
sort of treats us like the World Bank
that you just sort of dip in whenever
you need something
um and that is a step too far speaking
of something about the discourse let's
jump to the to the last segment I wanted
to cover which is I've tried to dip a
little bit out of the race Source
politics stuff for the last couple weeks
especially the DeSantis Trump stuff
because people don't realize we are
still over six months away from the
first primary we have a debate next
month but the first vote will not even
be cast in Iowa until January of next
year and everyone's fighting and going
crazy so I've been trying to take my
pedal my foot off the pedal at just a
little bit but I thought we'd dive in
just to end Today's Show because I know
you guys we're all sort of roughly on
the same side of this thing uh maybe
with some differences I thought it'd be
interesting here's more from that daily
wire Place uh former president Donald
Trump retained a large lead in Iowa New
Hampshire and Florida following a boost
in the polls after his indictments
according to the latest Real Clear
Politics polling average Trump's
National polling sits at 52.6 percent
according to the RCP average DeSantis is
in second place with 21 percent former
VP Mike Pence holds third at 6.3 and
Haley and Scott come in fourth and fifth
with 3.5 and 3.3 respectively desantis's
polling average has leveled off around
20 nationally after jumping into the
race in late May
the governor had reached as high as 30
percent in some polls earlier this year
before he officially launched his
campaign Trump's large lead in the polls
comes as he has dominated headlines for
months following his April indictment in
Manhattan on 34 felony counts of
falsifying business records two months
later the former president was indicted
in Miami on 37 felony counts relating to
his handling of classified documents
many Republicans including some of
Trump's opponents of the GOP Primary
have defended the leading candidate
amidst his legal battles calling the
indictment's politically motivated
targeting of President bide Joe Biden's
Chief rival first let me just ask you
guys kind of philosophically Andrew you
first
um
taking my foot off the pedal on this
thing and just kind of letting it play
out people know my personal feelings
about this I voted for Trump I like
Trump obviously I think DeSantis is a
better choice at this point do you think
we could all take a breath do you think
that would anyone that's roughly on the
right at this point or might vote for
one of these guys do you think everyone
just kind of taking a breath might be
good instead of all the infighting of
course you're absolutely right about the
time here that this point in when
Hillary Clinton was running against
Barack Obama she had the basically the
same numbers that Trump has now Trump is
a amazing character he is a great
showman he is great at what he's doing
the Democrats are playing our passions
as if we were a church organ they really
have figured out that rage will will
help them and enrage makes us stupid
rage always makes you stupid so you
indict him unfairly he was indicted
absurdly in New York he was indicted
unfairly in the at the federal level but
because Hillary Clinton did almost
exactly the same thing he did and walked
away scot-free it's infuriating it makes
people want to support him he knows what
he's doing but if you listen to what
he's saying his message is gone his
original attachment to the common sense
solutions that made him actually a good
president for three of his four years uh
is is kind of lost he just was saying
whatever he thinks people want to hear
DeSantis has a better record the santis
is blowing this he is doing a bad job so
even though it's far out he has got to
change his game his people do not know
what they're doing they don't have any
sense of social media they don't have
any they don't have any sense of the
modern media whatsoever he walks around
talking about Florida like Allison
Hannigan talking about band camp in
American Pie you know I mean he just
keeps bringing it up you know that's not
what California cares about it's not
what Iowa cares about that said he's got
a couple of good things his his pack has
a good ground game in Iowa ringing on
you know they're knocking on doors that
always helps but until they let this guy
get out with the people and humanize
them a little bit and let let them see
that he is somebody with a plan he
doesn't have to be a trump showman the
biggest thing he needs and the problem
no one in politics has saw is how to
attack Donald Trump because that's who
he's running against how to attack
Donald Trump without becoming Donald
Trump and that is and that is the thing
he's going to have to figure out before
this gets into the fall and winter but
you are absolutely right Dave this is
too too early to decide where this is
going to go it's not too early for the
Santas to start thinking about what he
needs to do to become a national
candidate by the way I I actually agree
with that assessment and I would love to
see Governor DeSantis go on the view and
say right to their faces the things that
we're all saying about the view and wool
culture and all of that stuff like he
can do it and he should I think he
should offer to go on Rogan he shouldn't
you know just do my show and and daily
wire and things of that nature so we'll
see about that but actually let me throw
to your point Andrew uh Maria Bartiromo
had the governor on I think this is
yesterday and they talked a bit about
what's going on with the campaign yeah
and you've done a great job pushing back
against woke we know that but I'm
wondering what's going on with your
campaign there was a lot of optimism
about you running for president earlier
in the year but here's this weekend's
headline from the Politico Playbook
Failure to Launch Florida Governor Ron
desantis's campaign to topple Donald
Trump has stalled we are way behind says
a top DeSantis pack official sounding
the alarm what happened
oh Maria these are narratives the media
does not want me to be the nominee I
think that's very very clear why because
they know I'll beat Biden but even more
importantly they know I will actually
deliver on all these things
so Andrew I I actually oh sorry uh
Spencer I actually agree with the
senatus there and I think it's almost
sort of silly for Bartiromo to quote
Politico when we know they're an
activist organization not a journalistic
outfit uh but the point is he should be
probably doing that on more combative
Television right yeah you know it gives
me no pleasure to say this because I uh
on balance would prefer to see DeSantis
win the nomination
um but there's a likability problem
there and I didn't quite expect it I
think that I and maybe DeSantis himself
uh who were laboring under the pleasant
delusion that simply being an extremely
competent and right thinking politician
was enough of an advertisement to the
American people and to the Republican
Party
um it's not right and so there's there
is this big issue about you know how
he's presenting himself how he's getting
his message across
um in a weird way my dream scenario
um which is in some ways the most
distant scenario is for us to have a
presidential fight between Ron DeSantis
and Gavin Newsom um and and not because
Gavin has my heart in any respect at all
but just because that would actually
represent the fight that we are having
at the national level a lot of this
other stuff is distraction to me um and
a key point about drawing back uh taking
a deep breath is that leaving aside you
know the moment when we will all have to
choose which candidate we vote for in
the primaries and then ultimately in the
general
um it is a bad idea for us as
conservatives to start slitting one
another's throats this early it's
already going to be a bit of a bloodbath
I think this fight between these two
camps
um you've seen some really nasty stuff
emerging into Nissan Warfare
um and I just don't think it's it's
worth it because the truth of the matter
is although this is a very important
presidential election and what's more
important is the energy of the new right
and DeSantis has genuinely been a major
figure a major leader in that part of
the conservative movement he will remain
that way I hope sincerely that he bucks
up his campaign
um it would be a delight to see him run
on his record in Florida if what he was
saying is I'm going to turn the whole
country into this essentially these are
going to be my issues and compare that
to the apocalyptic hellscape run by
Lizard Man Gavin Newsom all of that
sounds like a great message to me um but
it's sounding stiff and wooden and it's
not really it it seems to be relying uh
alas on competency and and skill which
is actually unfortunately not enough
yeah I think we have a little bit of a
tortoise hair situation here and the
Tortoise does win so there's time to go
but also keep in mind it's like Trump
announced back and what was that that
was October of last year and even now
we're still as I said six months away
from the primary so the the elongation
of this thing has just been absolutely
crazy I just want to hit one other thing
on on the presidential politics side
because Trump's main advisor at the
Izzy's campaign manager Jason Miller
he's the actual senior advisor uh Jason
Miller went on TV and he was asked
whether Trump is actually going to
debate uh and here was his answer
what is going to be the deciding factor
on whether president Trump does or does
not participate in the debates
great question at the moment president
Trump has indicated that he's unlikely
to participate at least in the first two
debates he's up by 30 40 and even new
polling shows he's up by almost 50
percent in certain places it really
wouldn't make much sense for him to go
and debate right now with a bunch of
folks who are down at three four and
five percent even Rhonda thank this
who's a second place candidate in the
race currently is at least 20 30 or 40
points behind and so ultimately
president Trump will make a decision as
we get closer he has not said anything
definitive one way or the other I'm not
expecting him to participate though
all right the first uh first off the
fact that the spokesman can't even say
DeSantis his name probably I'm just so
sick of that and I think more and
more people are but okay they're just
going to do that that's fine uh but
Andrew this idea that just because
you're so far ahead now National polls
also don't mean anything because you
have to win primaries not National polls
but let's say it's all legit and he is
up by all those numbers to me that does
not excuse you not going to debates if
we are ever going to get out of the
lunacy that that Spencer was just
talking about we have to be able to
debate ideas and if you're up by a ton
you should be able to debate them
confidently so I think it's going to be
a major hit for him if he dips out of
these two debates what do you think I
think it's going to be a hit the balance
you always have to play is that if
you're that far ahead you have nothing
to win in a debate you can only lose in
the debate because he's so far ahead the
other side of that balance is that you
look like a wimp and you look like you
can't participate especially afterwards
when he comes out and starts calling
people names and starts you know
refuting their points and everybody says
well why didn't you show up and do that
to their faces why do it behind their
back Trump has still got a bit of Teflon
on him he sinks solo the name calling
and the idea that you know people are
losers and all this kind of stuff that
comes out of his mouth that to me people
do not understand how off-putting that
is to a large swath of Voters it is why
he lost he did not lose because martians
took the machines and changed the votes
he lost because he's a rude boorish man
who treats people badly even when they
work for him and that comes back to bite
you and it came back to bite him and I
think you know at some point at some
point people look at that and turn away
but so far he's just been golden and the
reason for that is because that's who he
plays on TV so everybody already knows
who he is and thinks that's just Trump
but at some point yeah you hope people
come back to reality instead of reality
TV by the way Andrew I I try to give you
credit on this one every time you're on
the show I think it's worth mentioning
again that we were together at the daily
wire Studios on the night of the the
Trump election with Ben and Jeremy and
the whole crew and you said something
that really framed those first few years
of the presidency for me and ultimately
got me to be a trump supporter I think
in a certain respect because you said on
that night when the thing happened that
nobody thought Could Happen Trump became
president you said wow only in this
country can that sort of thing happen
and that's a beautiful thing that we
have in America because in most
countries the thing that you don't think
can happen can't happen and that's the
problem
with everything yeah Spencer my other
thought on Trump dipping out is that
it's this is just my opinion but it
seems fairly obvious to me that he has
cut a deal with vivec that vivec will be
the attack dog on DeSantis so what he's
doing basically is I'll step away and
vivec you're going to go all in and do
all my dirty work at the debates
do you think there's any legitimacy to
that well I have no idea whether he's
cut a deal or not but even if he hasn't
um that is the scenario that he's going
to gain by stepping out of the debates
naturally if he absents himself uh and
the big dog steps away uh the number
twos the perspective number twos are all
gonna try to take up take out the next
biggest dog
um so I would imagine if you're trumped
that's part of your strategy right you
want the Chris Christie's and the viveks
of the world to go for DeSantis and then
once they've taken him out you want
Vivek to take out Christy or Christy to
take out the fake or whatever however it
shakes out
um you know I just don't know what we
learn from debates anymore there's maybe
maybe this is like too structural a
point but it seems like the the
spectacle of people getting up on TV and
yelling at each other has been turned by
social media into a predetermined
conclusion like we kind of all know what
we think going into them it's not
totally clear to me that we change our
minds except as as dad says to sort of
like turn off uh undecided voters so uh
I I if I were Trump I would also like
probably think about stepping away from
the debate because what do you have to
what do you have to gain and you know
you do sort of then throw DeSantis as
like a piece of of meat to the rest of
the of the pack which you know it's not
that's not unintelligent well fear fear
not guys because as I said we have six
months until the first primary so may
God help us all uh gentlemen before I
let you go for the weekend I'm gonna do
a post game show over at
reubenreport.locals.com in just a moment
am I a honorary claven after spending
this much time with you in a respectful
manner absolutely not initiation yeah
it's just extremely elaborate dark if
you survive actually exactly yeah
on that note it's been a pleasure seeing
you guys we're a link down to a link to
your stuff down below and yeah we're
going to continue post game uh
reubenreport.locals.com have a great
weekend guys and we'll see everybody on
the other side well thank you very much
you know uh
foreign
[Music]